- I got to say, we had your husband on
the show a few weeks ago
and first of all, I hope he had fun,
but also when you entered this screen,
like I've seen you in
movies, but I was like,
oh man, no in real life you
really are that attractive.
And I was like, way to go,
DeVon, way to go DeVon.
You did well, sir.
I was like, geez,
you entered the screen and I was like,
is that what we we're
supposed to look like?
I don't understand.
Anyway, you are, you are not
only so beautiful though,
you're so talented.
I love the films that you're
in and I love your spirit
and I love DeVon, he was
so awesome on the show.
Did he have a good time?
- Thank you.
Yes, he definitely had a good time.
He had a great experience,
so I was so excited when I
found that I get to come too.
- I know at one point
I want you both here.
I want it 'cause I think
that dynamic would be funny,
but he talked about
how your relationship
got better in quarantine
and well, that is well
the opposite for my life
and maybe a lot of other people.
So do you, do you feel the
same that it did get better?
- Oh yeah, I do.
- Wow.
- It's weird because you
know, because of our jobs
we're often like ships
passing in the night
and I'll be gone for
you know, three months,
four months, seven months at a time,
he'll visit when he can, he'll
be gone for months at a time.
So for us, it was a
chance to just sit down,
take a breather,
take each other in,
enjoy each other.
I started cooking more,
he started baking more.
So we started cooking and baking together
and listening to music and
we decided to get marriage counseling
just in the spirit of
like, let's be proactive.
Let's go look underneath the hood
and see if there's anything that maybe
hasn't been dealt with
or that we can work
through it, whatever it is
and we did it for like
probably five or six months
and it was amazing.
Just the things that you discover that,
you know just the trauma, past
traumas that you both have
and there's always an
opportunity to just be proactive
in the marriage and say,
let's not just do something
if something happens,
but let's go do the work
and make it as, as you
know, as good as we can.
So it was a, it's pretty amazing,
it's definitely a transformative and
yeah.
- I think being
proactive about it, that's amazing.